today we have to leave mommy go hunting
for dragons
[Music]
there you go there's yours and and
there's your shield you need that to
protect you from the dragon fire all
right guys here we go out and look for
dragons let's do
[Music]
oh yeah okay all right let's see it go
over there
[Music]
sir Nathan the Dragonslayer and Tommy
the polar bear of the north
you guys are go inside and get some hot
chocolate all right if we can go inside
you get some hot chocolate
I mean or do you want to go down the
slide once all right get going hold
useless urge for you now I'll hand it to
you up at the top
[Music]
yeah keep going scoot forward
[Laughter]
here you go sir Nathan here's your
here's your show a seal all right yeah
hey guys having fun slaying dragons all
right David you ready to go and say you
get some hot chocolate marshmallows
biscuits
[Music]